ونحن سالنا الناس في الاردن والسعوديه
برايك من خطف الانظار بمظهره في العرس
الملكي الاردني نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
وقد خلق الله سبحانه وتعالى لنا ازواجا من
انفسنا لنسكن اليها
[موسيقى]
لا امير ما شاء الله عليه يعني هو بتوقع
هو اللي لفت بنظر اكثر واحد
ميرا اكيد الانسه نجوى هي من اكثر الناس
يعني اللفتوا الانظار
[موسيقى]
الملكه ما شاء الله الملكه رانيا بتجنن
بتجنن عن جد حلوه كتير كتير
[موسيقى]
عبد الله ما شاء الله عليه احسن من هيك ما
في
[موسيقى]
اكتر واحده كان شكلها حلو العروسه رضوى
الفستان والطرحه وكل شيء مره حلو اكثر
حاجه مفيده فيها التاج التاج كان جميل قوي
بصراحه مكتوب عليه رجوه من الله اكثر احد
لفت نظري الاميره كيت مره الامير ويليام
والله العريس لانه العريس ما شاء الله كان
يعني الزي حقه جدا جدا انيق زي عسكري اكثر
حد لفت نظري الملكه الامير والحسين هي
اكثر ملفته للنظر عجبت
ني وفستانها كان انيق جدا انيقه الامير
الحسين
كان اللبس حقه كلاسيك وحلو
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات